An expat is Andrew take after eight years as a barrister followed by nineteen years as a member of the New South Wales
they did stiff assembly eleven of them on the front bench Andrew tink stepped back from active politics in two thousand
and seven to concentrate on writing.
Andrew's first book William Charles Wentworth one the N I V
and I B I should say CIA away from the award for literature in two thousand
and in the second Sydney was published in two thousand and eleven and he stood a disaster Cambra in two thousand
and thirteen Andrew slightest book a strike nineteen one to two thousand and one
and narrative history was released in November two thousand
and fourteen Andrew is an edge on Professor University's Law School
and a trustee of Sydney living museums in two thousand
and thirteen he was awarded an honorary doctorate of late it's University and on the strategy I three thousand
and fourteen he was made a member of the Order of Australia in January two thousand
and fifteen Andrew commits to three year appointment as president of the lottery Council the south while he's going to
be talking to us the soft unknown on the subject of Magna Carta is round about relevance to early New South Wales
and I'd ask you to welcome him thank.
Thanks very much diverted look there's one thing that I need to explain and that is so I've had radiation for cancer
and I get a very dry mouth so to drink from this bottle with on but it can Times water not alcohol.
According to the Philosopher
and jurist Jeremy Bentham the detention of what he called explored convicts in the colonies was a breach of Magna Carta
which he said applauded New South while. As well as in England.
Such was Bentham's prominence in the light and early not a centuries
but are expected to find numerous references to Magna Carta in the early colonial records of New South whiles
especially the early court cases.
Diving clock mention the waiting case of fighting twenty seven
when the Zonda stood him it was the presiding magistrate who literally saying Magna Carta is prices not the litigant
but apart from this I couldn't find any mention of Magna Carta you know either the cush or reports
or Dowling select is which between them cover many of the court reports between seven billion ID ite
and I Ding forty three given these striving in Senate swep saw I climbs that Magna Carta reason much quoted by strident
when they're representing themselves in court cases I wondered why their ancestors didn't appear to do a lot more lies
perhaps I was smart a litigant seen person that knows more modern litigants that die the clock referred to a little bit
earlier that fellow in court coins land to say you had to coin something.
At one level it can be argued that Bentham was wrong
and that it was nothing in our the transportation act of seventy ninety four the active part of the status in New South
Wales which prevented a convict term expired from returning to England other than the extreme distance
and great expense involved
but that does not necessarily explain in the absence of other references to the great shot at you know the new South
whiles what might help to do so is the fact that from as early as July seventh I the common Lords applauded the convict
colony head in a kiddie respect lept I hated that applaud in England so we've bought clothes thirty Nawin of Magna
Carta as agreed to by King John in twelve fifteen there was an acknowledgement of the primacy of the common law
and this was recognised as one of the minor ongoing legacies of the settlement.
Between the king
and his barons at Runnymede then in some wise from its earliest dies earliest colonial dies New South Wiles was ahead
of England when a kind of fundamental rights had been this be so
when an examination of rather early colonial records such as newspaper reports
and dispatches between New South Wales officials
and the British government reveals that there's nothing about Magna Carta or until twenty seven
and then on the a few mentions the police are out by I think thirty one.
In my view the
and so last principally with Lord Sidney who was probably responsible sending the First Fleet to botany by
and with the convict colonies first and fifth governess to Philip unlocked
and McQuarrie large Sydney that are in Lawton Maine.
Over the last light hundred years the importance of Magna Carta has waxed
and wind the summit continues to be the defining recognition of ancient liberties reaching back at least the time of it
with the confessed up for others the great shot it was never more than a tenuous place truly between King John
and his rebellious barons
but even this more strict it view employed a direct challenge to King John's climb to rule by divine right
and it was the Stuart Kings climbs to rule by the will of God alone in the seventeenth century which guy Magna Carta
renewed relevance when Charles the Second asserted in the sixteen I.T.S.
That God had put him on the throne
and I only God could remove him it was Lord Sydney's great right Uncle Algernon Sidney with an eye who counted in
discourses concerning government that quote the peril regionally in the people of England is delegated into the power
of men and we might therefore Chinese
or Tycho white kings in discourses Sydney laws specifically on Magna Carta to support his proposition that to depend on
the will of a man is sly free Sidney said the intent.
Variances this was without doubt to establish this among us by Magna Carta similarly to Granny's assertion that laws
are not my boy kings because nice ones will be governed by a rule
and not really Sidney wrote The Great shot of that recapitulates
and acknowledges their rights in inherently bodies applaud just the king to swear that he will not have the sill to lie
in order not justice to any man according to the laws of the land.
For writing discourses
and they have boy daring to challenge King Charles a second's climb to rule by divine rule out right.
Sydney was tried for treason and found guilty
and on the seventh of December sixth he was beheaded there are after they become a moderate hero to those who believe
that the will of more not should be subject to the will of Polman among them Tommy Townsend a drop of the blood of
Allison on Sydney's vines towns in proudly told the House of Commons ninety years after his future execution after
suffering setbacks during these early power Mantri career as a government hack always one of those once upon a time
Townsend began to support radical causes among them that of John Wilkes who had been repeatedly expelled from power
meant for defaming King George the third Good to be repeatedly reelected boy's constituents.
To perfect the plan of securing and guiding the liberties of the freest nice in the world against the future attacks
and we could ministers were expert clime built on the firm Bice's of Magna Carta backing Wilks to the hilt Tommy towns
and address the commons the members of this house must not ask whether the man whom the electors have chosen he's fit
company for them towns and saide he acquires an indisputable total to admission by that election
and that election a line. Is the author of the American Declaration of Independence.
Thomas Jefferson Leiter acknowledged.
Algernon Sydney a billion one of these inspirations in discourses Sydney it is that nothing can be more evident than
that of many manage being created equal mirroring this in his declaration Jefferson famously proclaimed We hold these
truths to be self-evident that all men are created equal Alsono in Sydney is very very bright political philosopher
indeed not understood these dice because it was impossible to really which is to cite was a great think about a bad
writer if you want to be remembered well.
During the American Revolutionary War Tommy Townsend remind Truda Algernon Sidney's principles bowing among just a
handful of members of the House of Commons who strongly backed the revolted American colonists as George the third like
to call them all wrong McLean the new British government which emerged on to the war Tommy Townsend because I'm home
secretary responsible for negotiating a peace treaty with the Americans.
Is if it's to provide for American loyalists the king Often him a peerage
and that why Tommy towns in the kind lowered Sydney then off the United States refused to accept any more British
convicts it felt Lloyd Sydney to find an alternative.
Refusing to adopt Jeremy Bentham spree puzzle to build a jaunt penitentiary
or pan up the can so cold because it allowed a single watchman to observe all the inmates with at the end might spring
I will tell whether that obeying watched Sydney settled on a resumption of transportation this time to botany by.
The stewards of the transportation act of seventy ninety four which Lord Sydney to help to sponsor the British
Parliament convict oversea is quite could inflict such moderate punishment as might be inflicted boil on persons
committed to a house of correction.
So the convicts had substantial wrought sound of British law just as they arrive as cities had substantial
responsibilities and as is now being generally accepted by a story and generous provision was might for the.
Governor Philip kept
and what contains sport it was left to acting Tallie from resigned judgement without the benefit of a council
or other legal arrangements more in the spirit of Magna Carta he had been a he had been agreed to by Sydney
and Philip to the constant sort of the legal arrangements more in the spirit of Magna Carta had been agreed to by
Sydney
and Philip to the consternation of the First Lord of the Admiralty among these was an instruction of the convicts would
be subject to the ordinary criminal law and not to the hotshoe middle military law which applied to the Marines
and pursuant to let us patent would Sydney established a court of civil jurisdiction which could hear an action upon
complaint to be might in writing to the court
or any personal persons against any other personal persons residing wellbeing within the said place of any cause.
He's a story that will strike what these millions implying which. Is the first Floyd was bullying my ready.
Convicts were handed over to the master of the convict transport boy they July John Simpson one of them six Susanna
Holmes was accompanied by her infant son who the master of the transport refused to allow on board a pole that mother
and child would be separated because the child of course hadn't been convicted of an offense in the didn't have any
legal Bice's to tyke him.
Simpson took the infant and rode up to London where he hoped to remonstrate with somebody
and I'm office upon arrival Simpson bumped into Lloyd Sydney so the Home Office was very small just four rooms on the
first floor of a rinky dink building in want hole and unli for him.
Floyd by the Home Office including the secretary of state
and the lighting I ran the British am Paul the most the internal government right Britain I got into
when you station on the wire hand there most of the night and people running
when you'd station something's not quite right.
Size Simpson bumped into a load seen him silf it was quickly convinced to sign the pipe as that would allow the infant
to accompany its mother
and almost as an officer what he saw on pipe was allowing the by the father a convict by the name of Henry Cavill to go
to the person got hold of his story and Kibo homes
and they buy be quickly become celebrities so much so that the public dynamited to a trust fund to help them on a wider
botany by in their wisdom the trustees put his clothes and books which were placed in a Haitian sack
and loaded onto the transport Alexandra the Khyber on another vessel
when Khyber went to collect the sack after arriving at Sydney he was told by the Alexanders Masjid Duncan Sinclair that
the clothes that gone missing
and I knew the books could be found Meanwhile the court of civil jurisdiction had been a step wished
and so after typing advice Kai will sued Sinclair for damages
and following a three day hearing in early July seventh a ninety I presided over by the judge advocate David Collins
Kibo was awarded fifteen pounds in damages so it was that in Cairo versus single at the first civil suit brought in a
strike a convict successfully sued the monster of a first fleet transport for lost luggage you wouldn't do as well as
that to die if you took on course.
As a convict on the sentence Khyber would have been and I will bring these climb for damages in England
but in the convict colony different rules were applied
and in this why the common law which laws at the heart of Magna Carta was more advanced in the convict call
and even it was in the all country it's on really critically important story.
Even in the face of general stop I shouldn't govern I know so I should say that I do agree with John who is the we've
got to do something about the plot and in Canberra it's not wrong.
Even in the face of general starvation Governor Philip exercised these enormous past wisely
and this combined with these personal examples such as accepting the convict Russian help the colony to survive just as
important was the judicious use of the PAL would see the need given him to emancipate well behaved convicts
and grant them land
when Phillip the part of the seven day ninety two he handed I have a temporary control of the rum colcannon DA this I
should in years of instability as light
and I will govern a struggle to was there a thorough by now politically entrenched coal
and its fellow traveller is according to Jeffrey Watson down I see I see there's still a lot of
and well some allies played.
The simmering tensions finally climaxed on the twenty sixth of January
when the ram coal command of my johnson arrested governable on a ship in government at a time
when Britain was fighting for its lot of guys the French this decided the least was a risky strategy
and so on surprisingly Johnson my no specific reference to Magna Carta The justify himself even so he's dispatched of
account Council right had a familiar ring to it.
Calvin a blog tried the high trust and confidence reposed in bars sovereign and acted up on a pro to term
and plan to subvert the laws of his country to terrify and influence the courts of justice
and the persons who had the misfortune to be of noxious to him of the fortunes the liberty
and the laws one act of oppression was succeeded by until a general sense isin of alignment terror profile throughout
the settlements.
Johnson to council right if King John had not so on the Magna Kadar in twelve fifteen the barons model of drawing up
something similar. Notwithstanding the Sion any.
It's between the early governors in the colonies political factions many inhabitants of doing doing well in no small
part to the Polje to the policy Lord seed needs sitting trying of emancipation and land grants
and thanks to the in-laws
and inside of the colonies fifth governor Laughlin McQuarrie recognized in a new policy which head on sure this is
right had now president in England so this is another example of the colony the convict calling looping ahead of them
of a country
when it comes to fundamental rights on the thirtieth of by providing tain McCoury right to vote I can't council write
off Teigen upon myself to adopt a new law of conduct conduct conceding that conceiving that emancipation
when you nodded with rectitude
and long Troy good conduct should lead a man back to the rank of society which it full fitted
and do a why in his far as the case will admit already respect for my bad conduct he supposed to me to be the greatest
inducement that could be held there towards the reformation of the manners of the inhabitants
and I think it is consistent with the gracious fiber of this class of people Corey then explained that he allowed for
X.
Convicts to dawn with him the principal surgeon dasi Wentworth He's assistant William Redfern the prosperous farmer in
the land Andrew Thomson
and the wealthy merchant Simeon low wall Wentworth had never in fact playing convicted of anything it was widely
believed that he was a next Harlem and not without reason on one side.
I have long conducted themselves with the greatest propriety McCoury said No I find them at all times ready to come
forward the most liberal man it was the systems of government to award this McCoury
and bars to beat a point in Thompson as a magistrate in the Hawkesbury and he would soon appoint Wentworth
and Lord as magistrate seen Sydney had Jeremy Bentham span up the can being built it's difficult to imagine that would
ever of to live it fully reform convicts on the skyll now contemplated by government quarry nor would.
Led to see it as magistrates in England I'm sure I'm writing sign in this why the administration of lore in the colony
had a lip that England
but the prospect of being judged boy offended many of the cycle exclusive for a setlist I'm not sure that if I go hold
up before a magistrate in Paramount of all I would be very happy if I knew the irony that a name like.
That I never catch their objections these are the exclusive for the set was playing just boy.
They never cast their objections in terms of Magna Carta close thirty nine of the twelfth edition we would have allowed
them to do so and I for a man should be persuaded against it says except for the lawful judgment of these pieces.
Nevertheless the exclusives objected to London the batiks convict magistrates in there and why
and as a result Commissioner John Big was appointed to inquire into the McCoury administration
but the governor didn't help him so when he to forward the commission
and appointed another ex-con William Redfern to the bench.
It was Das he went with son William Charles Wentworth who made the first comprehensive piece for constitutional reform
of the convict colony.
In a statistical historical and political description of the colony of New South whiles a book written
and published in England a night a night went with proposed the introduction of Troll Boy jury a free press
and elected legislature and an independent supreme court
but nowhere in this book of almost five hundred pages is there a reference to Magna Carta rather resolve humans for
putting more general terms it's a fundamental maxim of the British constitution went with right that no taxes should be
levied on the subject without his consent expressed voice Representatives even to this maxim the rod is in directly
from clause twelve of a. Right shot of that's the one of a story twelfth which begins.
That society was in a military tax nice good age no rights will be imposed on at Kingdom unless part Common Council of
that kingdom which is a no taxation without representation. And.
Argument according to some following on from Commission a big reports uniting twenty two an independent Supreme Court
was established limited Troll Boy jury was implemented
and appointed Legislative Council was established to Cory successor Thomas Brisbane also introduce what he called the
experiment of the four letter to the freedom of the press
and she supplied English concessions in the second edition of each book went with the written in the Mind on its
probable with all these privileges which the author has contended for will be considered accepting perhaps full trial
by jury and the establishment of a house of assembly
and if these privileges withheld little longer it will only be from the conviction of the colony hasn't yet Iran
sufficient degree but you're ready for the reception an exercise of them.
The granting of these further constitutional concessions was ultimately an issue for the British government and pollen.
And having been taught a lesson by the revolt of American colonists less than half a century earlier it was a matter of
when not if.
Jury
and elected legislature would be introduced However while a man supposed legal for these Chinese assoon as possible some
exclusives for the vigorous regard the lying action motivated especially by the prospect of being judged by juries of
X.
Convex another complication was Gov Brisbane successor Ralph dolling a prickly military mot net who broadly that any
criticism of his administration of the colonies now often pointed newspaper editorials indeed it was the convict.
Conflict between dolling
and those pushing for reform which triggered the only direct official reference I could find on Magna Carta up to white
in forty four to petition the king in both houses of parliament full trial by jury
and elected legislature a public meeting was held at Sydney's courthouse on the twenty sixth general twenty seven there
are a large crowd was addressed by William Charles Wentworth these Constitutional Rights belong as much to the people
as the crown belong to the king he said I was a birthright of the people and nothing
but the strongest necessity could justify withholding them an instant So the petition itself set out to show why there
was not just this no such necessity withhold them any further in relation to jury trials the petitions were careful to
point out that the competency for trial by jury has been proved boy upwards of two years' experience in that mode of
trial in the colonies courts of Quarter Sessions therefore the inference was that to extend it to all jury trials
carried very little risk it would be any incremental China which it was in relation to the call for an elected
legislature of the petition involved to grant China referring to the colonies annual revenue of sixty thousand pounds
the petition is quite this enormous sum this isn't here the two billion levied on your Majesty's humble petition is
both already of power meant that other was without their consent contra to Magna Carta
and that ended the dispatches back to.
England as an excuse to the governor as official dispatches to the well by then colonial secretary
and that's how it was in the official record.
While the editor of Sydney's monitor news Piper described as contrary to an expressed quote was in Magna.
My view is that it isn't based on a bleak reference to close twelve which I mentioned earlier.
Whatever the case the petition then addressed itself to the practical matter of whether they are enough people.
The call only qualified to stand for election their idea.
Of the magistrate magistracies the petition argued
and three times as many gentlemen who will take will be fitted by their will
and talents to act as members of alleged to the assembly such a Govern a darling unimpressed
and he's covering dispatch which accompanied the petition of the Colonial Secretary Lord Bathurst presentation to the
king darling said it started of in infancy at present reigned in New South Wales unfit for those institutions which in
England as a result of its advancement
and maturity now then anticipating this went with a swing to what the copies of the petition would be taken to London
by Gregory Blaxland
and they are presented to sympathizers in bypass of Palma as the editor of the city morning monitor put it Lord
Bathurst is not as cold he will towards the house of the same.
We're glad therefore the parliament is Billion petitioned as well as the king.
Live this campaign for constitutional reform had some years left to run.
I could only find to read lighter references to Magna Carta up to white in forty three
but which time trial by jury in a posh elected legislature introduced into New South whiles the first reference was in
a letter to the Sidney is it published in the thirteenth of August twenty nine quoting the letter
and version of Magna Carta schools thirty nine of the.
Twelve edition there are derived that the free born children of a man's a man suppose should have the benefits of
unlimited trial by jury.
And the second reference appeared in an article in the stride in the thirtieth of July thirty climbing that upon the
principle of Magna Carter a verdict of twelve main is to be a verdict of law the piper criticized
and identified court judgment on the BY says that a positive jury verdict for the defendant had been replaced by a
special verdict of the judge this was in fact a reference to the items.
Of pine number two according to the official court report the attorney general had a lab the case to go to the jury
and I found a verdict for the defendant against the direction of the judges who ruled that upon the playthings the
crown was in top of the judgment the defendants barristers Wardell and Wentworth that's W.
So he went with admitted on appeal that in strictness of law the defendant not might add any total against the Crown
but instead that iniquity the verdict stood as the colonies to foreigners barristers Richard Wardo
and William Charles Wentworth must have known that their argument would not succeed so perhaps it's no coincidence that
the appeal to Magna Carta appeared without attribution in a news pipe which Wardell
and went with had founded back in twenty four.
All are specific to references to Magna Carta during the convict colonies first dies a few
and far between the nine of the last man to be executed for invoking it has been celebrated since the twenty second of
January seventeenth night
when Governor Philip nine Sydney after the home secretary Lord Sidney half so well thought of you
when he'd been offered a peerage for his role in securing a peace treaty with the revolt of American colonists the home
secretary then still known as Tommy Townsend charged the nine Sydney for the top will in on are of these revealed
and Algernon Sidney Algernon Sidney with and on.
So why is there a difference in the spelling between Sydney's we now with the law
and Sydney with the on in fact first proposed Sydney with a no i did George the third
but then he discovered what he called the elder branches of his family might have a climb on it so he rode to the king
a stall lies the consideration of the toilets occupies my thoughts no farther than to avoid taking.
Anyone which might clash with the pretensions of any other family if your Majesty will allow me to Chinese the toilets
of Sydney with a wife sitting with a wall of chisel Hirst neither of which a climb boy anybody
and to which on the law I'd bar the Sydney's in the V.
Is one hundred more relatives will be satisfied in that all offend nobody else in this roundabout why then the I'm a
BAD RIGHT city celebrates Algernon Sidney the last man to be modded for invoking Magna Carta against an absolute as
British King thank you. Thank you.